bist du bereit
die weg von meinem pkw
spielen halt einfach das was peytons
erstes auto war
gold
weißt du was die hier alle mit dir
gemeinsam um
kapitän schlechter job kündigen diese
flaschen
so fällt euch übrigens fragt warum ich
neuerdings diesem bumblebee auch
festgestellt habe so 1 9 und 2 gt3 und
nicht mehr den 02
ich hab dann so auch im bild auf
instagram hochgeladen und ich habe
einfach eine gute quote bekommen für den
hier aus münchen vom porsche zentrum
münchen ganze begrüßen joshua das macht
auch einfach in jeglicher hinsicht mehr
sinn dass ich den turbo s verkauft habe
und mir gt3 gekauft habe ich noch alle
leute die sich damit auskennen wissen
das auch
[Musik]
so sieht jeder deutscher park aus
wenn ich bei mir auf augenhöhe film
sieht man nicht einfach so wie kann man
sie zu deine augen
denn er jetzt im rolli macht bin ich
cool
ja das werden
das sieht übrigens die elbe falls ihr
euch fragt zielgruppe sind alle tiere
sollte ein recht darauf haben freie
leben zu können so wie ich denn ich bin
das stärkste tier von allen oder sagen
wenn man jetzt ja gerade vier euro pro
person bezahlt für das minigolf echten
fairer preis ich dachte eigentlich
teurer auf jeden fall sind wir gott
planten un blomen minigolfanlage ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass das bei samstag
in hamburg so voll ist aber gut werden
jetzt gerade unseren einen strand kasten
einmal bekommen den zettel zwei
verschiedene bälle blau für alle bahnen
weiß das netzteil dass es in spring ball
ich weiß nicht wer sich diese scheiße
hier angucken machen blogs wie die im
haus in die luft springen nicht auf bahn
nummer eins sich als erfahrener mini
golf profi
[Musik]
ich als erfahrener mini golf profi zeigt
euch jetzt hier erstmal die bahn bauen
dürfen natürlich nicht betreten werden
im roten
blauen roten und loch von daher zeichen
dass in einem schlag macht darum nicht
ladies first
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in einer richtigen party
passt kannst du eigentlich
becker sehr
zufrieden bist du mit deiner leistung
das ist jetzt mein erster schlag
um schlag habe ich es geschafft habe ich
zeige euch das geht wie soll ich jetzt
mal raus kriegen oder das ding zu
betreten
erstes fällt luca einen schlag pages
erster schlag den erstmal zur seite
geschoben jetzt geht so was mal schauen
ob das auch mit nur einem schlag schafft
ich bin gespannt das ist
so schlecht sein wollen wir auch so eine
perfekte kamera halterung
last lag da und nabu und klickt auf die
glocke
was so auf einen schlag von peter der
wahl geschoben den werden wir nicht
einmal geschoben zurück hätten
zurückgeschoben du darfst nicht schieben
du darfst nicht schieben
nein peyton der kunden zurück die dritte
auf die basis ist disqualifiziert
fantastische
christine rose ich habe mich angepasst
fahren nummer zwei freunde ich erkläre
ich brauche hier wieder ganz kurz wir
haben einen looping
dadurch ein anderes loch ich schwöre
euch jeder minigolfplatz hat die
gleichen bands genauso mit
frühlingsrollen habt ihr hier schon mal
eine andere frühlingsrolle gegessen als
bei einem anderen laden dass luca sagen
wollte frühlingsrolle schmeckt einfach
egal wo man sie ist gleich jetzt mache
ich den looping
aber ich bin durch das ziel das was
geschoben gegen weltmeister
[Musik]
du machst nicht erst mal klar machen
genommen nein du machst das mehr los so
dass sie sehen nicht wahr
wir sind jetzt auch schon beim versuch
nummer 6
diese sind wir dann auch beim versuch
nummer 6 das er gibt gar keinen sinn
uns schon
etwas für temperatur im echten spitzen
scheißegal also eine direktwahl alter
nie wieder gehen
eine zeitlang als ich nach hamburg
gezogen wurden freunde von minigolf
aufmachen dann fragt die spieler
abschießen kann nie geklappt ich war
einmal mit ich habe nur gesagt ich habe
nicht gespielt ich bin ist da musst du
auch gehst du auf dieser bahn schon mal
nein
disqualifiziert das ist und du hast
vorteil weil du schon mal hier war
hätten halt den ranken
wenn ich scheiße ein zweiter schlag hier
auf der bahn da
natürlich gerade den sitzen verarschen
ich für uns einfach mal so dann sie aber
nicht komplett
über den fernseher
qualifiziert muss da nicht weiter ich
wusste auch nicht weitermachen nein das
ist wieder
ganz gekonnt eine 12 auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die klassischen sinn für dich juncker
erster schlag war das schreiben wir auch
hier wieder eine 1 auf bei der bahn
wir haben so viel spaß sha la la la la
wir haben so fischer
waren wir mal 4 wir müssen uns noch ein
und dann dahinter wenn es noch ein floß
geht's los
ich bin der spieler ich darf den
scheidungsrichter bloß gesagt okay
an dieser stelle habe ich ehrlich gesagt
einfach noch mal ein komplettes leben
hinterfragt guest golf der richtige
sport für mich
oder sollte ich lieber bei anderen
sportarten bleiben ist einfach in dem
moment alles an mir vorbeigezogen
spieltag leute ich glaube wir
konzentrieren uns wirklich mal ein
bisschen aufspielen war den ganzen
schwachsinn mal beiseite melden uns dann
nachher mit unseren ausgefüllten zettel
exakte 36 minuten profi minigolf
schlechthin meine damen und herren haben
wir dann auch die 18 bahnen der planten
un blomen minigolfanlage beenden können
wir jetzt werde ich mitspielen ich zeige
euch jetzt mal den finalen score den wir
gerade ehrlich erwirtschaftet haben
peyton hatte eine gesamtzahl von
1.000.000 45 1380 und ich von 1
es hat auf jeden fall sehr spaß gemacht
wenn euch diese extrem beschissene
minigolf loch gefallen hat das kann
einen daumen hoch unter dem video aber
nicht meinen kanal und klickt auf die
glocken weitere videos nicht zu
verpassen auf instagram ist ein neues
bild online gegangen mit meinem auto von
daher leicht das gern